[Music]
I am the greatest video game player on
the planet oh this this is just my [ __ ]
from mice night I don't even know her
name
another agario whoa
[Music]
this is the tail of lead [ __ ] oh you
play as a tank in this game
that's cute I'll tank all them hoes if
you know what I mean saying this game
you shoot blocks you level up it's just
like minecraft no one really attacks
each other in this game everyone is just
a little [ __ ] don't you worry
as soon as some levels up I'm gonna
wreck these hoops okay we got upgrade
what should we go for twins that's it
baby keep growing longer oh oh get [ __ ]
on oh [ __ ] did you see that [ __ ] babe
she's unconscious but don't worry she
she consent take this
yeah dude zero deaths wake the [ __ ] up
babe you're missing the [ __ ] game
player of a lifetime over here what is
with the Illuminati [ __ ] [ __ ] off okay
we can upgrade triplet just [ __ ] yeah
yeah you got destroyed [ __ ] oh you want
some you want some you want to play a
game you want to play a game you want to
play a game [ __ ] you want to play a
game [ __ ] you want to play a game [ __ ]
yeah that's right [ __ ] she dead I
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] noobs running
away from us welcome to the game [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] dead
Oh mister OH in the world you want to
fight you want to fight me you want to
fight me I'm just stronger some other
[ __ ] on this planet have you ever
sucked it no I blink back go back go
back
why do I keep hitting the button bring
me back bring me back for [ __ ] sake oh
you kidding me you [ __ ] [ __ ] you did
this god dammit I picked the worst
[ __ ] class I'm not leveling up fast
enough
this is polish yes assassin assassin
ocean
you own
oh you just got assassinated [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
I'm so good at games Oh more like are
you dead oh god I'm [ __ ] quickscope
my mother saw me right now she'd be so
proud
[ __ ] you got [ __ ] that was for your
mom don't worry about the girl she's a
nice lady
oh no so close
[Music]
we're not [ __ ] dying from you
[ __ ] this game this game is for [ __ ]
[ __ ] whose [ __ ] spray brother you
came zero-depth that doesn't count
this doesn't mean [ __ ] you didn't see it
you didn't see anyone zero depth I'm
here to become number one in this game
let's do it I am here to become the
greatest number one player in the
universe that's it baby
more levels welcome to the real world
hey dude I'm your friend
why [ __ ] he thought I was its prey come
here gorgeous come here you're good
good bye gorgeous goddamn it come on
buddy
[Music]
like I wrecked your mom's ass Oh
headshot oh that feels good
Oh [ __ ] came out of nowhere
oh we're number two what the [ __ ] coming
from number one I told you guys I am the
greatest player on this [ __ ] planet
I'm catching up to these [ __ ] Oh
mine can feel my muscles getting bigger
I said more I play a hole get rich
oh my god no no come back to me wake up
wake up wake up
I love
[Music]
wake wig
you
they said I haven't actually died zero
times well they were wrong I have
returned to destroy this game for once
and for all my [ __ ] is gone it's just
you and me now oh I'm shaking
oh it's shaking over here I am so pissed
number one number one or die that's me
baby we're gonna level up so [ __ ]
fast you don't even know level two [ __ ]
give me that bullet damage there are
deaths I'm having so much fun we're
going with the sniper Oh came out of
nowhere
hey buddy see you in Hell Punk oh oh hey
Sony why don't you make some good games
sorry I love I'm a big fan actually good
night sweet prince
Hey look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] we're top
10 but we're coming for number 1 or
we're out got'em hey welcome to the game
[ __ ] [ __ ] bane
I hate my [ __ ] face what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] was that my haters thought
I couldn't do it my [ __ ] my [ __ ]
almost left me but here I am on top of
the world number one and number two is
not even near I am the greatest player
on this planet in this universe hey
fella why don't you suck my Fetty if you
know what I mean a oh we started with
YouTube and we finished it with dye peel
you know what I don't even care about
this game I'm so strong nothing can
destroy me I'm too strong I'm too strong
I'm too powerful nothing can defeat me
nothing we'll just whatever whatever I
don't care I got my [ __ ] I'm out peace
out embrace [ __ ] this 0d i hope you
enjoyed this video if you did leave a
like I appreciate it remember to
subscribe kids and as always stay
awesome race
[Music]